Sega has said it's investigating
high-definition releases of the first
two Shenmue games but noted that
licensing issues are creating some
complications I'm Dave and welcome to
your forklift driving news update
speaking in an episode of Sega central
Sega Europe community manager Dan
Sheridan said the company would love to
release these tomorrow sadly it's not as
simple as porting the games to the
current platforms we need to ensure that
any HD remaster lives up to the quality
of the original titles with games as
immersive as Shenmue and Shenmue 2 there
are further complications involving
licensed products that were included in
the original games that said we'd love
to do it and are currently investigating
how to make it reality Japanese version
of Shenmue featured coca-cola vending
machines which were replaced with jet
Cola in the Western releases it may be
that they are among the licensed
products that are causing issues a
Kickstarter campaign for the third entry
in the series was revealed during Sony's
e3 press conference last year and it was
funded in record time it very quickly
exceeded two million dollars and as a
result a number of the project stretch
goals have also been met this
effectively expanded the scope of the
game to include a skill tree and a
rapport system as well as additional
quests and expanded areas the Shenmue 3
website states over six and a half
million dollars has been pledged Shenmue
3 is scheduled to come to both PC and
PlayStation 4 with Sony helping to
market and produce Shenmue 3 but won't
be receiving any of the money raised
through Kickstarter so would you play a
remaster of the classics on today's
consoles let us know in the comments
section below or find me on Twitter at a
regular Dave and for all your Shamu news
stay tuned to games.com